on a faim de cadeaux des fins de très
très bonne idée avec votre iphone failli
faire chaque fois de très belles
sélections et là on va jouer aux pirates
oui un petit les montagnes on part à la
mer au mois de mai chez nous il ya de
très beaux la quinta il faut voyager oui
alors là les illustrateurs et les
auteurs jeunesse ont décidé de revisiter
le thème du pirate et du coup le premier
je vous propose c'est le petit pirate
des étoiles de michel bussi et peggy
o'neal c'est édité par la langue au chat
et en fait c'est un petit pirate qui vit
sur une île déserte alors ça commence
traditionnellement comme une histoire de
pirates le problème c'est qu'il est très
petit celles plus petites sa famille
donc on lui interdit tout on lui dit oh
tu verras quand tu seras grand
mais il ne grandit pas alors il décide
de faire un voyage initiatique de partir
à l'aventuré comme n'importe quel pirate
mais dans sa navette donc dans sa fusée
spatiale et quand il revient et bien il
se rend compte que tout le monde a
vieilli sauf lui
alors vous voyez c'est une sorte de
conte philosophique sur le temps qui
passe la relativité du temps et sur eh
bien les liens familiaux
c'est très joli je veux pas vous en dire
plus parce que il faut toujours garder
un peu de mystère sa part le collège est
passé à partir de 4 ans et puis sans
limite d'âge mais vous voyez ça termine
bien puisque à un mariage à la fin quand
même et pour la petite histoire en fait
michel bussi j'espère si vous le
connaissez c'est un auteur de thrillers
il est très connu dans le roman noir et
cette histoire là on fait est extraite
un d'un roman qui a eu un grand succès
qui s'appelle maman a tort dont la vue
sur la couverture maman en fait raconter
une histoire elles sont plus chères
histoire et son enfant et du coup ils
ont décidé d'extraire en fait c'est
l'histoire la littérature
wiroth des étoiles voilà du bonheur
histoire de pirates c'est un petit peu
comme les histoires de cow boy ou de
policiers
finalement finalement il ya beaucoup de
bagarres il ya beaucoup d' aventure dans
tout ça il n'y a pas que ça en fait non
maintenant parce qu'on peut mettre aussi
de la philosophie par exemple avec léo
mille questions vous voyez son crochet
on voulait du crochet tout à l'heure a
été remplacé par un point
d'interrogation alors c'est un livre
d'anthony ce papa était au double ou et
iris ça mardi comme qui nous vient de
grèce et vous voyez ce petit pirate
comme il est un peu différent personne
ne veut l'embarqué sur son navire à part
le capitaine joe qui lui donne sa chance
et c'est une bonne idée parce que
figurez-vous que grâce à ces questions
il va permettre aux pirates d'évoluer
d'apprendre de gagner des batailles
d'innover et donc sa différence fini par
être une force c'est un très joli livre
pour dire aux enfants que vers 1 il faut
qu'il pose toutes les questions
oui il est pour moi un petit peu sur
nous et notre ami léon là parce que je
lis alors que les autres pirates comment
ça pendant ces chiens chats maman papa
lui dit qui quoi quand comment pourquoi
essentielle gros potentiel on peut aussi
bien compris c'est après coup en fait
qu'on va se rendre compte de votre
chance par le passé mais non c'est un
très joli livre justement pour montrer
aux enfants cubains partir caser toutes
les questions d'appareil à partir de 4-5
ans et puis bah vers 8-9 ans peut lire
tout seuls et puis on se laisse pas
forcément de ce genre de livre bah c'est
super ça pour les enfants on va pas se
le cacher on besoin d'évasion
comme nous les parents donc c'est plutôt
bien on rêve parfois parfois aussi à la
piraterie et ça donne des choses assez
surprenante
le livre que vous nous avez emmené là
une bouffée on va dire d'hermach 1 on
prend un grand bol d'air frais et ça ça
fait du bien oui alors c'est un livre
assez particulier ça ne fait pas penser
immédiatement aux pirates ça s'appelle
le garçon du phare mike duco mais c'est
une vraie histoire d' aventure
imaginez vous êtes chez vous vous êtes
un jeune garçon vous est gardé par votre
soeur adolescente
alors évidemment comme ça vous dit j'en
ai marre elle s'occupe pas de moi vous
dans un accès de colère vous arracher
votre papier peint un peu un enfant
tyran et qu'est ce qui se passe derrière
un rocher du ciel bleu une vague c'est
un passage secret vers l' aventure et la
conti mottet passe de l'autre côté ils
rencontrent morgan et deviennent amis
c'est une histoire de bataille de duel
il faut affronter un monstre marin
c'est un livre magnifique vous le voyez
tout à la gouache un livre de max du coc
que je vous conseille nous placer plutôt
un bel album à partir de 8 9 ans c'est
magnifique vraiment les illustrations et
c'est un très grand format ça fait
plaisir sous le sapin
les très grands même plus c'est gros ça
mais je suis là les enfants et aux
parents qui essaye toujours des lyrics
bon mais je pense que nos petits
flibustiers vont être particulièrement
content pour les plus grands il ya aussi
des grands classiques forcément des
choses très très grandes dents dans la
piraterie
je crois qu'il ya un livre qui dresse
notamment le portrait d'un des pirates
les plus célèbres de l'histoire est bien
même de tous les pirates les plus
aguerris en avoir roulé en soliste et
par le williams évidemment marc euros ce
qui je peux vous citer d'autres francis
drake et barbe noire surcouf aussi et je
voulais vous en parler parce que tous
les autres sont des gentils pirates ans
et puis là je voulais vous parler un peu
des terreurs de la piraterie voilà c'est
un livre de caroline faye et gillian de
roche qui a fait les gravures
c'est magnifique savoure tresses un peu
leur parcours leur histoire ça vous
inspirera peut-être si vous avez
quelques mauvais coups à faire comme si
je faisais le mauvais coup à la barre
david heymans et des tirades du 16ème au
19ème donc mon c'est plus compliqué
maintenant et vous savez que les pirates
ça existe encore si tu perds on adore
les pirates
la sélection mérite évidemment retrouver
sur le net forcément en pilotant france
3 est fait avec tekka et références
voilà et sur les écrans connectés super
libraire évidemment